♪♪
>>> AFTER DECADES OF SILENCE,
THE CDC IS SPEAKING UP ABOUT
AMERICA'S GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC.
THE GUN VIOLENCE ARCHIVE REPORTS
EVERY WEEKEND THIS SUMMER MORE
THAN 200 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN KILLED
ON AVERAGE AND NEARLY 500
INJURED.
AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
CNN'S ELIZ BETD COHEN CDC
DIRECTOR ROCHELLE WALENSKY IS
ANNOUNCING WHAT SHE PLANS TO DO
ABOUT IT.
THIS IS UNUSUAL FOR A CDC
DIRECTOR TO SPEAK LIKE THIS.
>> IT IS.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING UP FOR YEARS NOW,
RIGHT?
GUN VIOLENCE KILLS TENS OF
THOUSANDS AMERICANS A YEAR.
IT'S CLEARLY A PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT, BUT ACTUALLY FOR THE
PAST ABOUT 25 YEARS CDC
DIRECTORS HAVE BEEN PRETTY MUCH
SILENT ON THE TOPIC OF GUN
VIOLENCE.
THE FEAR WAS THAT THE MORE THEY
TALKED THAT THE NRA, THE
POWERFUL GUN LOBBY WOULD
PRESSURE CONGRESS TO MAKE MORE
CUTS IN CDC'S BUDGET.
BUT IN MY EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH DR. WALENSKY, SHE SAYS IT'S
TIME TO SPEAK UP.
>> Reporter: GUNS --
>> YOU SHOT THAT GUY IN THE
STOMACH.
>> Reporter: THEY LEAVE A TOLL
OF DEATH AND DESPAIR ACROSS
AMERICA.
MASS SHOOTINGS --
>> THE SHOTS JUST KEPT COMING.
WE WERE GOING DOWN, WHEN WE GOT
DOWN, THERE WAS A MAN THAT WAS
SHOT RIGHT THERE.
>> Reporter: URBAN VIOLENCE.
>> WE HAVE A VICTIM OVER HERE
WITH GUNSHOTS WOUNDS TO THE LEFT
AND TO THE CHEST.
>> Reporter: ROAD RAGE.
>> HE SAID, MOMMY, MY TUMMY
HURTS.
SO SHE WENT AND SHE PICKED HIM
UP AND HE WAS BLEEDING ON HER.
>> Reporter: SUICIDES.
>> HE WALKED INTO A GUNSHOT AT
11:02.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 3 AND 4:00
P.M. THAT AFTERNOON HE SHOT
HIMSELF.
>> Reporter: WHILE AMERICANS
HAVE BEGGED FOR AN END TO THIS
VIOLENCE --
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO LEAVE.
>> Reporter: THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION IS A POWERFUL FORCE
IN WASHINGTON.
>> SEMIAUTOMATIC FIREARM
TECHNOLOGY HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
100 YEARS.
THEY'RE THE MOST POPULAR GUNS
FOR HUNTING, TARGET SHOOTING,
SELF DEFENSE.
>> Reporter: IN THE 1990s THE
NRA CONVINCED CONGRESS TO CUT
ALL OF CDCs FUNDING FOR GUN
RESEARCH, A LOSS EQUIVALENT TO
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A YEAR.
FEARING FURTHER CUTS, CDC
LEADERS PUBLICLY WERE ALL BUT
SILENT FOR DECADES.
EVEN AS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS DIED FROM GUN VIOLENCE
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR.
BUT NOW IN A STUNNING TURN, THE
CURRENT DIRECTOR OF THE CDC IS
ANNOUNCING A PLAN TO REDUCE GUN
VIOLENCE, SHARING EXCLUSIVELY
WITH CNN.
>> THIS IS ACTUALLY A STUNNING
MOMENT THAT A DIRECTOR OF THE
CDC IS EVEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE, IS EVEN USING THE WORD
GUNS.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED IN YEARS AND
YEARS.
>> EVERYDAY WE TURN ON THE NEWS
AND THERE ARE MORE YOUNG PEOPLE
DYING.
I SWORE TO THE PRESIDENT AND TO
THIS COUNTRY THAT I WOULD
PROTECT YOUR HEALTH.
THIS IS CLEARLY ONE OF THOSE
MOMENTS, ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
THAT IS HARMING AMERICA'S
HEALTH.
>> Reporter: BUT THERE'S A
REASON WHY YOUR PREDECESSORS
DIDN'T ADDRESS IT.
>> PERHAPS.
>> I WANT TO SHARE --
>> Reporter: WE'RE USED TO
HEARING DR. ROCHELLE WALENSKY
TALK ABOUT THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC.
>> VACCINE IS A TOP PRIORITY.
>> Reporter: THIS IS HER FIRST
INTERVIEW ON AMERICA'S EPIDEMIC
ON GUN VIOLENCE.
>> WE HAD 74 PEOPLE SHOT IN ONE
WEEKEND IN CHICAGO.
THAT SAME WEEKEND PARTY IN
FLORIDA FIVE TEENAGERS SHOT.
THAT SAME WEEKEND A MAN IN NEW
YORK CITY IN TIMES SQUARE SHOT
IN THE BACK AND THE LIST GOES ON
AND ON.
WEEK AFTER WEEK AFTER WEEK.
CAN ANYTHING BE DONE ABOUT THIS?
>> SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE
ABOUT THAT.
SO 40,000 FIREARM-RELATED DEATHS
A YEAR.
120,000 SERIOUS FIREARM-RELATED
INJURIES PER YEAR.
THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM IS JUST
BIGGER THAN WE'RE EVEN HEARING
ABOUT.
AND WHEN YOUR HEART WRENCHES
EVERYDAY YOU TURN ON THE NEWS,
YOU'RE ONLY HEARING THE TIP OF
THE ICEBERG.
>> >> Reporter: WHEN YOU WAKE UP
ON A MONDAY MORNING AND YOU HEAR
ALL THE REPORTS, THE CHILDREN
WHO WERE SHOT THE PREVIOUS
WEEKEND, CDC DIRECTOR, WHAT DOES
THAT FEEL LIKE TO YOU?
>> THAT'S HEAVY.
IT HURTS.
IT HURT BEFORE I WAS CDC
DIRECTOR.
I THINK ANY AMERICAN CITIZEN
THAT TURNS ON THE NEWS JUST
CAN'T FATHOM ANOTHER ONE OF
THESE MASS VIOLENCE ISSUES.
>> Reporter: DR. WALENSKY'S
STRATEGY, RESTART THE GUN
RESEARCH.
>> MY JOB IS TO UNDERSTAND AND
EVALUATE THE PROBLEM, TO
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM, TO UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
HAPPENS AND WHAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT CAN MAKE IT BETTER.
TO RESEARCH THAT, TO SCALE THAT
UP, TO EVALUATE IT AND TO MAKE
SURE WE CAN INTEGRATE IT INTO
COMMUNITIES.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE AREAS
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T DONE A LOT OF
WORK AS A NATION FOR ALMOST ANY
OF THEM.
>> Reporter: THIS TIME SHE WANTS
THE CDC TO FIND COMMON GROUND
WITH GUN OWNERS.
>> LET'S AGREE WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO DIE.
LET'S AGREE THERE.
>> Reporter: SHE WANTS TO ALLAY
GUN OWNER'S FEARS.
>> GENERALLY THE WORD GUN FOR
THOSE WORRIED ABOUT RESEARCH IN
THIS AREA IS FOLLOWED BY THE
WORD CONTROL.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I WANT TO DO
HERE.
I'M NOT HERE ABOUT GUN CONTROL.
I'M HERE ABOUT PREVENTING GUN
VIOLENCE AND GUN DEATH.
>> Reporter: AND WANTS TO
INVOLVE GUN OWNERS IN THE CDC
RESEARCH TO SAVE LIVES.
>> I'M AFRAID YOU WANT TO TAKE
AWAY MY GUN.
>> AND MY ANSWER IS COME BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION.
COME TO THE TABLE.
JOIN US IN THE CONVERSATION.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO FEEL THAT
WAY.
RIGHT?
I WANT YOU TO TEACH ME WHAT YOU
HAVE DONE TO MAKE YOUR GUN SAFE.
AND THEN I WANT YOU TO TEACH
EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> Reporter: DR. WALENSKY'S PLAN
HAS BROUGHT HER HERE TO VERMONT
TO HELP SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
ACCORDING TO A 2015 STUDY, IN
THE UNITED STATES AN ESTIMATED
4.6 MILLION CHILDREN LIVED WITH
A LOADED AND UNLOCKED GUN.
THAT NUMBER HAS LIKELY INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY SINCE THEN.
>> I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG --
>> Reporter: THESE CHILDREN IN
VERMONT ARE LEARNING HOW TO
SHOOT GUNS AND HOW TO STORE THEM
SAFELY.
A GUN OWN R AND AN ENERGY ROOM
PHYSICIAN TEACHES THIS 4H
COMMUNITY PROGRAM.
>> HOW DO WE KEEP YOUR GUNS HERE
AT 4H?
HOW ARE THEY STORED?
>> Reporter: BY FUNDING THIS
PROGRAM AND STUDYING WHAT THEY
DO -- AND REPEATING IT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, DR. WALENSKY HOPES
TO PREVENT ACCIDENTAL GUN DEATHS
AMONG CHILDREN.
>> CDC IS HERE, WE'RE HERE
BECAUSE TODAY YOU'RE OUR
TEACHERS.
WASN'T TO LEARN FROM YOU.
>> Reporter: THE CDC IS ALSO
FUNDING THIS PROJECT AT GUN
SHOPS TO HELP PUT A STOP TO GUN
SUICIDES.
>> IT'S A POSTER THAT TALKS
ABOUT HOW GUN OWNERS CAN HELP
DIFFERENT SIGNS TO LOOK FOR.
>> THE DOCTOR KNOWS THAT DR.
WALENSKY WILL GET PUSH BACK.
>> WHEN GUN OWNERS HEAR THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE CDC WANTS
TO REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE.
WHAT DO THEY HEAR?
>> I THINK AT THE ON THE OTHER
HAND OF THE DAY THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT GUN CONFISCATION.
DR. WALENSKY STANDS FIRM.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED THAT SAYING
THE WORD GUNS OR TALKING ABOUT
FIREARMS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
GET A WHOLE SECTOR OF THE UNITED
STATES JUST REALLY ANGRY?
>> OF COURSE.
I ALSO WORRY THAT IF WOE DON'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT WE HAVE A
WHOLE SECTOR OF THE UNITED
STATES THAT'S REALLY ANGRY.
>> HOW HIGH A PRIORITY IS THIS
FOR YOU?
>> THIS IS ONE OF THE LEADING
KILLERS OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S A HIGH PRIORITY.
>> WE DON'T KNOW IF THE NRA IS
GOING TO FIGHT DR. WALENSKY ON
HER INITIATIVES.
THAT GROUP IS HAVING THEIR OWN
LEGAL AND FINANCIAL ISSUES.
IT'S UNCLEAR IF THEY HAVE THE
STRENGTH TO MUSTER MUCH OF A
FIGHT.
>> THAT WAS REALLY INTERESTING
DISCUSSION AND TIME SPENT WI